This could be my last chance
the moment of truth
bringing out the big guns
shouldn't be down here i
can be wherever i want nurse
it's doctor actually you're
still the help just like me
get out
michael
don't shoot
step back
what the hell is that thing
fall back
Welcome back everyone this is my new morbius
trailer video they just released another clip
of the movie like an extended clip of him
transforming into morbius for the first time
so we'll break it all down there's a bunch of
easter eggs here we also learned about some more
connections to spider-man no way home what's going
on with venom let there be carnage the post credit
scene and how everything is slowly crossing over
through the multiverse or the spider verse however
you want to think about it we're doing a giveaway
for imax tickets for spider-man no way home all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave your favorite moment from this new
trailer on the video i think the real battle
that's going to be happening in january when
this movie drops is people deciding which is
better morbius or venom let there be carnage
venom is a vastly more popular character in the
comics but we'll have to see whether the morbius
movie because they had so much extra time
to polish it winds up being a better movie
overall than venom let there be carnage after all
the crazy andrew garfield and tobey maguire easter
eggs in this along with tom holland spider-man
no way home easter eggs it just seems like a way
more interesting movie than we thought that it was
about a year ago but this scene is meant to pick
up after he's already been infused with the blood
from those special bats that you see in the other
part of the trailers in the comics he doesn't
get bitten by a bat that's not how he gets his
powers he doesn't get bit by another vampire they
did a version of this during the spider-man 1990s
animated series which is a fantastic tv series
if you haven't seen that but that did a pretty
good job of adapting a version of his comic
book origin story so they develop a genetic
treatment involving the blood the dna from these
special bats that you see in all the trailers
treat him with that and that's what gives him
his powers like it kind of mutates him instead
of transforming him the way a traditional vampire
would like you get bit by a vampire you turn into
another vampire or to make a spider-man reference
you get bit by a radioactive spider and you get
spider-based powers ever since i got bit by that
spider and during this clip if it wasn't clear
they are being more accurate to comic book morbius
so the difference with the 90s animated version of
the character is that because it was a children's
tv series or relatively young person tv series
instead of having him drink blood they gave him
these weird hand suckers that took the plasma
out of other people's blood so he wasn't running
around biting people in the cartoon but in the
comics he does drink blood like other vampires
so that's why you see him drinking blood during
a lot of these trailers he needs to drink blood
in order to survive and that's what's happening
during this first transformation here like they
treat him he slowly begins to transform until
he gets triggered when he sees martine bancroft
hurt by some of these mercenaries here they seem
kind of like mercenaries because they're such
big like they seem a little bit sus like some
of this is not totally above board like he is
at the end of his rope when he goes to this
south american country or wherever it is that he
finds these bats thus you get all these really
quote-unquote bad people on this boat that he
winds up taking out it's just another way for
them to play him more like an anti-hero like yes
he is killing them he is drinking their blood
growing more powerful but they are kind of
terrible people it's the exact same thing they
did with the venom character during the first
venom movie and then venom let there be carnage
were only going to eat bad people adria ronha is
playing martine bancroft which is morbius's love
interest from the comics they also did it during
the animated series as well the minor change from
his comic book origin that's happening during this
clip is that the boat that he transformed on for
the first time was actually with his friend which
is the character that's being played by jared
harris so there is a version of that origin story
where he accidentally winds up killing his friend
because he can't control himself he can't control
his powers as morbius it seems like there's a
version of that that happens in other parts of
the trail or different part of the movie the
whole deal with matt smith's character you haven't
seen a ton of him in the trailers yet because he
is supposed to be the secret main villain of
the film is that he's playing loki's crown
who gets sort of the same type of powers that
morbius has and just winds up using them for evil
so it's sort of flowing with the same kind of
villain energy that you get from the first venom
movie and venom let there be carnage where the
hero or the anti-hero is fighting an evil version
of himself venom having to fight the other more
evil symbiotes venom having to fight the carnage
character talking about more connections to
spider-man no way home through the multiverse so
you have michael keaton's vulture character during
this from spider-man homecoming we just found
out that he will be filming more scenes for the
morbius movie so it seems like they're expanding
on whatever the sinister six scene is happening
when he's breaking out of prison when more beasts
is getting hauled in that's what's happening
here in this scene morbius is being hauled in
while vulture is also at the same prison this is
in the new york city area where vulture got sent
to prison during spider-man homecoming morbius
eventually uses his powers to break out and then
vulture uses that as an opportunity to also bust
out of prison while he's quote unquote putting a
team together which sounds very much like a teaser
for a sinister six spin-off movie but like i
explained you have the versions of the sinister
six characters from tope maguire and andrew
garfield's spider-man movies in spider-man no way
home with the original versions of the characters
coming back the sinister six movies that it sounds
like sony is trying to set up the spin-off movies
will probably be slightly different rosters like
not all the villains from spider-man no way home
will probably come back in future movies maybe
a couple of them that will be really cool but
it sounds like the sinister 16 that vulture is
talking about is going to be a slightly different
roster my understanding is that morbius would then
theoretically cross over with other characters
he's not going to be part of any sinister six
franchise or anything like that like if he
showed up in a sinister six movie or venom showed
up in a sinister six movie they would be fighting
the sinister six villains they wouldn't be part
of the team but the idea is that eventually you
would see all these big characters that sony is
creating movies for these anti-hero characters
all crossing over in a giant avengers end game
type of movie infinity war or end game whatever
kind of comparison you want to make sony building
up to its own giant huge crossover event we just
saw a brand new trailer for spider-man into the
spider-verse 2 which is now called spider-man
across the spider-verse part 1 so they're already
kind of building up to giant avengers end game
type of moments i just did a deleted scene video
for knull god of the symbiotes where they were
kind of teasing him a little bit in the background
of venom let there be carnage so we'll add a link
for that at the end of this he could wind up being
their big avengers end game kind of moment they
don't have to go as big as nole that would be
really cool though there are other ways to have
a giant huge crossover event but early theory
right now that would be like a king in black or
absolute carnage kind of event but because he ate
carnage at the end of venom let there be carnage
it's a little bit harder to justify stories that
turn so heavily on the carnage character there
was a brand new spider-man no way home trailer
video that they released as part of the special
villains panel where he had the toby maguire and
andrew garfield villains like green goblin doctor
octopus and then jamie foxx's electro character
all talking about their characters and coming
back and what it meant for them and what's going
on with their characters during the events of
spider-man no way home it was same but different
it's a return to something i did before with that
kind of history but the spin there's a spin on it
alfred for me it's just about the money so i'll do
a video for that next be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that while you
wait for everything click here for my brand new
spider-man across the spider-verse trailer video
in easter eggs and click here for that venom let
the be carnage deleted scene for knull god of the
symbiotes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!